I actually like Kevin I think that  he's a great player I think he's  actually a good dude I think he's  insecure at times you know he gets mad  when the old guys like myself saying he  got to win a championship away from the  Golden State Warriors and I know he got  offended by that but that's not my job  to worry about people's feelings I think  the issue that comes sometimes from  players and people in the media is for  example right now for you to say I think  he's insecure right it's like what data  have we collected or what have  conversation have you had with him  personally to be able to label him as an  insecure person Taylor that's levels to  this you don't have to react to every  fool when I talk about insecurities like  yo man everybody's opinion doesn't  matter you don't need burner phones  you're Kevin Durant you can say whatever  the hell you want to but you don't have  to react to every single thing